so i am a new relatively new listener
just started with the pandemic and i've
been catching up and i noticed that you
and gorly
sort of throw out little history tidbits
from time to time and i really enjoy it
uh i think this is one of the only
podcasts where when i'm done listening
it i have to go google the references
oh of what you've mentioned right doing
that a lot and so my question was if
you um were to start your own history
museum what kind of
exhibits or artifacts would you like to
feature or have it be based around
wow that's a that's a really good
question uh i'm gonna
say 19th century american that's
probably what i'm most interested in
civil war era late 19th century it's
such a kooky time there's just so many
so there's civil war stuff you can have
in the museum but also it was a time
when people were
were were creating these uh
you know utopian and i put that in quote
societies
that that where everyone was having sex
with each other these kooky societies in
upstate new york what
yeah yeah i'm not kidding and and there
is
there's there's just filled with america
was just filled with con artists and
weirdos and freaks and not that we
aren't now but
but the 19th century uh such a
fascinating time to me
in america so that's i think what i
would what i would focus on
you know phrenologists were thought to
be very
learned men and they actually thought
that by feeling your head
and where the bumps are they could tell
things about you which is just
total [ __ ] and they had phrenology
heads that you've probably seen for sale
sometimes in antique stores that
if there's a bump in this part of the
skull it means that this person
is an arsonist you know just total
nonsense
i don't know i that's the world i would
like to live in and i would probably
walk around
in that museum wearing a waistcoat with
a pocket watch and i would have a
fake waxed mustache and i would sort of
talk in that old timey voice
and i'd say welcome to my welcome to my
museum
it's good and if you get hungry there's
a nice place walk and roll is next door
because it looks like you're an older
gentleman and i think it's
time to die that's what i would do
okay that makes sense because uh when
you started i thought you were
going down like a political route or
like presidential maybe like
monticello was like a secret house of
debacle debauchery sorry
i can't talk is yeah um uh and um there
was
you know there was some i wouldn't i
don't know debauchery is the word but
monticello is
kind of a fascinating place uh jefferson
was an inventor he was kind of a
kooky inventor and so his inventions are
all over the place
and uh the first thing you see when uh
you walk into monticello is he had a
clock that he didn't want to be
rewinding it all the time so it has a
really long pendulum
that goes through an opening in the
floor and like down into
a deep chamber so that it it can last
longer and the weights go down that way
too it's really crazy
so yeah i uh interesting but i'm going
to give me the 19th century that's what
it is 19th century
okay what's that sona lots of i'm just
curious about what these exhibits are
going to look like because you're making
it sound really like cool and sexy but
like you're
okay let me say something that's going
to differentiate my museum from other
museums i have a lot of connections in
show business
so okay come to my museum and you're
going to see
celebrities there dressed as different
historical characters
you know yeah i i have a lot of pull
with
with well-known people and um you know
so you know nicole kidman would be there
dressed i mean she's not gonna be there
every day i've talked to her about it
and she can't do it every day but she
can do thursdays so
nicole kidman would be there wearing you
know
some outfit that someone wore at
lincoln's inaugural ball
his first not his second you know and
and just standing there
yeah it's kind of standing like a living
statue and then you walk up to her and
you pre
you press a button and she would do a
quick scene about what it was like to be
there that glorious day talking to mary
todd lincoln and then she'd freeze again
and then you'd press the button and
she'd have to say the exact same script
uh but i would get all kinds of a-list
celebrities
to be there you know uh playing
different 19th century
people and it'd be the hottest ticket in
town let's make history
fun let's get a-list celebrities dressed
as 19th century icons
you know let's let's make this happen
let's get the rock dressed as mark twain
walking around saying things that mark
twain would say and i've talked to the
rock and he can't do thursdays but he
can do tuesdays
he can't do every tuesday but he's
pretty open in june and july
this is this is the kind of stuff that
i've been getting into
i think will there be like a wrestling
featurette well you know when you have
the rock there
there's going to be some pressure he's
got to wrestle yeah and
he's going to say i'm not the rock
anymore i'm duane the rock johnson and
i'll be like let's cut the [ __ ]
you know you're mark twain you're mark
twain and you're gonna wrestle
and you're gonna you're gonna wrestle
now and you're gonna wrestle liam
hemsworth
who's uh who's dressed as john d
rockefeller
you know and and that's just a good
museum right that's the best museum i've
ever gone to
yeah yeah it's really good beats the
smithsonian which is [ __ ] that museum